Speaker 1: I mentioned in the last
segment the name Kevin McCarthy.
There is an unbelievable situation going on
with Kevin McCarthy. Kevin McCarthy is the House
minority leader. He's a Republican. He Republicans
are in the minority for now in the House,
and Kevin McCarthy is their leader now. It
wouldn't be shocking because of what we know
that people like Liz Cheney in the aftermath
of the Jan. six riots we're talking about,
can we invoke the 25th Amendment to remove Donald
Trump? Should we demand that Donald Trump resign?
That's Liz Cheney. We know she doesn't like Trump,
but Kevin McCarthy is a guy who is the Uber Trump
loyalist, and reports started coming out last
week from the New York Times that Republican
House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy was going
around in the aftermath of the Trump riots, saying
Trump should resign. Trump should resign in
response to that report by the New York Times.
McCarthy denied the entire thing, and this
is this is such a brilliant series of events.
So New York Times reports that McCarthy denies
it. He put it puts out a statement saying
The New York Times reporting on me is totally
false and wrong. It comes as no surprise that
the corporate media is obsessed with doing
everything it can to further a liberal agenda.
This promotional book tour is no different
if the reporters were interested in truth.
Why would they ask for comment after the book was
printed? The past year and a half have proven that
our country was better off when Trump was in
the White House, and rather than address the
real issues facing Americans, the corporate
media is more concerned with profiting from
manufactured political intrigue from politically
motivated sources. So he denies that he ever said.
We got we got to look at Trump resigning, and
then Rachel Maddow got the video. The audio,
I guess I should better say after Kevin McCarthy
said, Oh no, I never said anything about Trump
should resign. Audio of Liz Cheney speaking to
Kevin McCarthy given to Rachel Maddow on MSNBC
proves it is all true. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Conversation, I hear thanks,
Kevin. Well, I guess there's a question when
when we were talking about the 25th Amendment
resolution. Yeah. And you asked, you know
what happens if I get there after he's gone?
Is there any chance? Are you hearing that he might
resign? Is there any reason to think that might
happen? I had a few discussions. My gut tells
me, No, I'm seriously thinking we're having
that conversation with them tonight. OK.
Speaker 1: That's Kevin McCarthy saying,
I'm thinking about talking to Trump about
resigning tonight. He denied that this
ever happened. Here it is on tape.
Speaker 2: Talk to me couple of days
from what I know of him. I mean, you guys are
known to do you think you'd never back away?
But what when I think I'm going to do it, you're
going to call him a liar? Just because what I? You
know, it will pass the house. I think there's a
chance we'll have to say involved. And I think
there's a lot of different ramifications
for that. I haven't had a discussion with
them that if he did resign, would that happen?
Speaker 1: So what I'm understanding this is, is
initially they were talking about the 25th
Amendment, but that's something the cabinet does.
My understanding is now McCarthy is saying if
he were to resign, would Democrats agree not
to impeach? That's my understanding of this part.
Speaker 2: Now this is one personal feel I have.
I do not want to get in in any conversation about
his party together. The only discussion I have
with him is that I think this will pass and it
will be my recommendation. It should be done.
Speaker 1: It would be my recommendation that he
should resign. So just caught caught. McCarthy was
lying. He said I never talked to Trump about that,
but I'm sorry. He said I never said I was going to
talk to Trump about that. I never said he should
resign. And there he is on the recording, saying,
I think he should resign. The reporters
have even more. Check out this piece of
an interview from The Rachel Maddow Show.
Speaker 3: So just just to underscore this,
just to be clear, Mr. McCarthy
and his office have denied
that he said he was going to call Trump and tell
him to resign. You have it on tape. We just heard
that he in fact, said that his also he
is also today denied that he called for
members of his own caucus, other House
Republicans, to have their social media
access cut off. You've also got that on tape.
Speaker 4: That's correct, and we have a lot
more on tape from this period, which is at the
highest levels of American politics. It is,
it is sensitive, it's delicate and
it's high stakes. And we have it all
on tape. And it's going to, I think, tell a very
different story about this period than the story
that many people are trying to tell right now.
Speaker 1: There is another recording that
they have where McCarthy says, I've had
it with this guy speaking about Trump.
Speaker 2: All right, and I know this is not fun
and know this is not great. This is very tough,
but what I want to do, especially through here,
is I don't want to rush things. I want everybody
to have all the information needed. I've had it
with this guy. What he did is unacceptable. Nobody
can defend that and nobody should defend of.
Speaker 1: OK, so that's pretty remarkable
stuff. Now, eventually, after all of the claims
that Kevin McCarthy made about the New York Times
article were refuted by audio reporters finally
got to McCarthy and they said, OK, so like
they got to right and McCarthy shifts
the goalposts and he does it pretty
smoothly. See if you can pick it up.
Speaker 4: Have you spoken with President
Trump recently? Did you speak with him last
night? I know I spoke to him twice today. I
just spoke to him an hour ago. How was your
conversation? Did you talk to him about
the New York Times report and the conversation
you had about potentially asking him to resign?
Because the conversation here is what they
what they said we did. We never did. I mean,
I never asked President Trump to resign.
Speaker 1: We both talked about that. So this
is the key point. We don't even need to watch
the rest of the video, McCarthy goes. I never
asked Trump to resign. Now, that may well be true,
but the claim initially was. McCarthy said Trump
should resign. And McCarthy denied it. And he's on
audio, saying Trump should resign. McCarthy wants
to say something different, which is I never asked
Trump to resign. That's not what he originally
denied. Now, does this make Republicans look
better or worse? One perspective is this makes
Republicans look better. They're not that crazy.
They saw how bad Trump was, and they wanted him to
resign. I say this makes them look worse because
what I understand is they saw how bad Trump was,
and privately they knew that this guy had
to go and he was a danger. But publicly,
they insist that everything's fine. Trump's great.
He's the greatest president. We support him.
They publicly supported a guy that they
knew was bad for the country, merely for
their own political benefit. So I believe
this makes them look worse. Now, last thing,
it's great that this is coming out and
everything. But why did it take a year
for this stuff to come out? As usual, it's the
authors holding stuff in order to sell books, and
I understand why they're doing it. I understand
the financial incentive. But for the country,
it would have been much better if these tapes
came out in real time. These conversations,
some of them happened on January 10th. I'm not
saying that if they came out on January 10th,
maybe the reporters didn't have them on January
10th. But if instead of a year later or more,
we knew in the moment that Republicans were saying
Trump should resign. It actually might have pushed
him to resign. I'm not saying it would have, but
it would have at least have had a shot. And now
it's 15 months later, six months later, and we're
learning about it now. That's not new. That's how
the business works. Incredible stuff about Kevin
McCarthy and what else will we find out in the
next week? Send me your thoughts. Find me on
Twitter at De Packman. The David Pakman Show is
a viewer and listener supported program, we depend
on the membership program to fund our show. Many
of us who have cable subscriptions unthinkingly
give three four bucks every month to Fox News just
through our cable subscriptions. I would invite
you consider a couple bucks to The David Pakman
Show by signing up at Join Packman dot com
and using the coupon code. Wow. Twenty two!